[Music]
i'll make you drunk with pride so deeply
spun into my system that you won't see
the light never mind that i'm drowning
you i
[Music]
keep you
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live today we got a
really cool guest this is pamela she's
been in a couple different bands but
what happened was one day brittany
played a song for us and it was just so
inspiring and she's going to tell how it
impacted her
but we want to introduce our guest
pamela how do you say your name again
something burg my berg
yeah my berg like my burger
so
brittany came into the office one day
and she's like i heard this song one day
at my church
well go ahead and tell where you're
right
yes so um i actually came across this
song a long time ago i want to say maybe
close to five years ago
and um it was just during a like a
little small group bible study that i
was in they were like you know we're
gonna we're like just the clothes they
were playing this song
and then um i remember watching it and
listening to the lyrics since they're on
the screen i was like wow this song is
so powerful
and then um
right at like maybe like a year or two
later
um our university did a skit it was like
um it was like the gymnastics team and
they did a skit with it
and then it's just it was just something
that stayed with me so then i don't know
what led me to remember it to share it
with you guys but it's one of those
things that just follows you and so i
shared it and then mikey ended up
becoming so obsessed with it yeah so the
song title is called in the words of
satan and basically you're
singing this very poetic i mean your
lyrics are so poetic to me i just love
the way they're written it just really
makes you understand like how deceptive
the enemy is like he's infiltrated in so
many subtle ways that so many people
just aren't even aware of and that's a
big passion that we have at this
ministry is
exposing so the show is light exposing
darkness that's what led stands for and
so we're always trying to show you look
there's subliminal there's subtle
messages in these movies there's subtle
messages in these songs
yoga is being becoming really popular
but it's not just exercises there's
things spiritual things that are
attached to that so we're always trying
to talk about
um you know
topics that people are dealing with
controversial things that people are
struggling with that they might not even
realize are dangerous and so when you
when i heard this song that was from 11
years ago now 11 years ago i was just
starting to kind of wake up to this type
of stuff but you already had a song
recorded
i'm curious to know how you got to this
point how did you get to a point where
i'm sure you had a life where you just
were like a normal person everything was
fine
and then one day you kind of woke up to
wow there's a lot of subtle deceptions
and dangers in this world because it
seemed like you didn't hold back any
punches there were
things in there that i was like whoa she
even she even threw that in there you
know
so i'm kind of just interested to hear
your story
were you raised in a christian home and
was there a moment where you kind of
surrendered fully to christ was there a
prodigal story or were you always a
believer and yeah i just want to hear
how you got to where you are now
sure hi everybody uh thanks for having
me today
um
yeah so with regards to that song it's
actually a very personal song it's
something that i wrote because i was
writing out of my own life
i
had been
in a situation where all of the lies at
one point or another that i discuss and
that i sort of unpack in that song i was
a victim of those lies so it's not like
something that i was writing from the
outside looking in it was something that
i intrinsically understood because i was
a victim of all of those deceptions in
many ways
and
i think that's why sometimes people hear
the song and they kind of hear it as
very judgy and very preachy and
bad bad bad and i'm like listen
i'm just being vulnerable i was at the
end i was on i was on the other side of
these lies which is why
it's actually like the song for me is
actually full of compassion
because
i know what it's like to be on the other
side of those lies and
that's where the song sort of came from
i
was raised christian
and then kind of fell away because i
believed that my parents were very
hypocritical i think a lot of young
people in the church
go through the same thing
just the the sunday face and going to
church and putting on your sunday face
but then the rest of the week my parents
fought like cat and dog
and anyway so it was just this
contradiction that i grew up with and i
was like you know what i don't want to
end up like you
because i don't like the way you live so
i'm going to not listen to the things
you tell me to do
and there was one moment the very first
lie the devil ever told to me that i can
remember i was about 15. i'll never
forget
as a songwriter i was starting to listen
to songwriters and to music that was
influencing me and that was making me
think differently and expand my
understanding of human emotion
and i'll never forget the first lie i
can remember the time i can remember the
place in my little room growing up 15
and here's this voice of satan we all
hear it so it's not going to sound
foreign for you
you're not going to be able to write
songs like this
unless you live the way they've lived
and learn this information for yourself
that was the first lie that i can
remember the devil told me it was
perfectly set up i was about to go on
the cusp of rebelling against what my
parents had taught me growing up because
i didn't believe them anymore it was
perfectly timed i was perfectly set up
and
bam here's this lie
and i took it all the way to the bank
i walked away from god in a
phenomenal way
and
it was years from when that first lie
was like incepted into my heart
until i actually could find my way back
to jesus it was years of just like
living completely away from god i had
absolutely no interest in understanding
the truth or in reflecting the truth
and
in that time of course there was drugs
there was bad relationships broken
relationships
lots and lots of wild crazy music
um and
just a lot of things that actually
separated me even further from god
which i didn't i didn't know was a bad
thing i was actually happy about it
because again i didn't want to end up
like my parents so i was like then i've
got to do the opposite because i don't
want to be like them
anyway
so that's years and years of living
separate and living away from god
and then
some there was
about seven or eight years later since
that first initial lie
then there came this yearning in my
heart
because i was so broken
and i was so i was shattered i was in
pieces because you can't walk away from
god and end up okay it's just like it
doesn't work
i had walked away from god and i was
completely in pieces and i was at the
end of myself and i was like
this the way that i'm living life now
i'm just broken and i need to fix i need
to be fixed and i need to feel fixed
so
i'm gonna start
going back to christianity i'm gonna go
and look for three months i remember i
was very
i'm very methodical
i'm gonna give jesus a chance for three
months i'm gonna do everything they tell
me to do
and if i don't feel better if i don't
feel free if i don't feel like
joy is coming back to my soul
then i'm gonna leave and i'm gonna go
try buddhism and i might end up in some
tibetan monastery but i don't care i
know that the missing connection in my
life right now is as spiritual is god
and
so i went to a bible college i moved
from the city that i was living in in
south africa to a different city from
cape town i moved to durban
and
went to a bible college
recommended by my mom listening to my
mom for the first time and god knows how
long at that time
but
going to this bible college and i agreed
with myself i'm going to do everything
that they say
and then if i feel better then
jesus is real and jesus is true but if i
don't
feel better then i'm going to move on
within three months
i had received jesus i'd actually
understood that i wasn't saved
i understood that i needed jesus and it
was all very clear to me
i received jesus
and then a couple of weeks later i was
delivered and had obviously intense
deliverance you know not like the
exorcism movie people don't understand
deliverance all the time
but there was ex like there was
definitely
a moment where i was delivered and you
know the demon left and well the demons
that were oppressing me
were gone and i'll never forget this
because i have a testimony for this too
how do i know that it was real
because as it turns out somewhere in
those seven or eight years that i had
walked away from jesus
somewhere on the line i'd gained a
different voice
and this voice used to bust me around
and it used to say don't wear that wear
this
don't stand there stand here don't talk
to these guys talk to those guys okay
now you got to go dance okay now you got
to go buy a drink okay now you just
bullying me around pulling me around
pulling me around bullying me around all
the time so much that i didn't it was so
it was so internal i didn't really
realize that it wasn't me
wow and i was delivered
and the next morning i woke up and i
opened my cupboard and the voice was
gone
and not telling me what to wear praise
god
not telling me
when i went to bible college that day
not telling me who to talk to not
telling me where to stand not telling me
who to hang with
and i was free
and in that
experience that was the experience for
me that i went okay
the whole bible is true
everything is true if that is true and
that happened to me then it's all true
and
that was the moment i'd say that i
really
after being delivered that i really
committed my entire gifting and my
entire life to the lord
was that moment because before that
i was happy i felt better
i was feeling joyful i was feeling peace
because i'd received jesus and i'd
received the holy spirit so i was
feeling the fruits of the spirit
but it was the moment of deliverance
that actually made me go you know what
i'm gonna sell everything i have
and i'm gonna live with this because if
this is true
people need to know about it
and i need to do everything that i can
to make it known
and that's
how i ended up writing the song in the
words of satan because
i know
that song is my life i'm not a christian
who's a goody two-shoes who's just
judging all the sinners i was that
sinner
i was
and those lies all of the different lies
and all the different things in the song
affected me in my life and
that's how that's how i got to the song
sorry that may have been a longer answer
than you were no
that's a phenom that's just a beautiful
testimony shedding light on the fact
that god answers his promises god keeps
his promises there's a bible verse that
says if you seek me you will find me if
you search for me with all of your heart
and you gave god was it three months hey
he would have worked with three minutes
if that's all that you gave him so that
is just so profound wow yeah
yeah i was noticing you said how
you one day you just felt delivered you
know
satan can is only allowed in if you're
giving him some kind of a gateway or
you know a door a foothold in i think
there's a lot more of those types of
things that we're just not aware of
because of our culture everything's
acceptable and you know so people
decorate their homes with idols buddha
statues and things like that and i don't
think we realize that some of that stuff
is inviting evil spirits in
and once you invited christ in he had no
authority to be in your life anymore and
i just think it's awesome that you know
you did give god that chance like okay
i'm i'm giving you this opportunity
because that's all he's waiting for he's
like finally yes because he's he's a
gentleman he's knocking on the door of
your heart he's not
battle ramming in in there you know and
just cleaning house he's knocking hoping
you'll answer and he's he's looking for
friendship
and
he's not going to force himself like the
enemy does the enemy uses all these
different
psychological tricks and subliminal
messaging and all these things that he
can
force his way into your life
and has a lot of success with it
but god's just waiting for that one
opportunity for you to just say okay
lord show me you're real and that's
happened in my life and like you said i
identified a lot with
those deceptions of the enemy and stuff
which is why
you know britney said i i'm kind of
obsessed with the song because when i
heard it i'm like
wow this is this is all true so was
when you said you were laying in your
bed or something and you were thinking
about wanting to become a musician and
the enemy was saying
you have to live like that you were
thinking about becoming like a secular
artist and the enemy was like well you
gotta live that lifestyle is that what
oh i was already a songwriter i was
already starting to embark on that
journey but
so the first lie that um i can remember
that the devil told me was like if i
want to write these type of songs like
if i wanted to write
these uh deep emotional like songs that
can touch other people that was it it
was more like why does the song make me
feel such a like intense i feel so
intensely about this music why was that
happening and then the enemy was like if
you want to have the same effect you're
gonna have to go on the same journey
it's like you're gonna have to do the
drugs you're gonna have to do the bad
relationships you're gonna have to do
the brokenness you're going to have to
do those things and you're going to have
to get that depth for yourself if you
want to have this depth in your music
yeah that was more what it was about how
can you have that awesome breakup song
unless you go through a terrible
terrible relationship right that's what
i wanted to get back to is is that first
thing that she said that first
experience because
so many people are told that you have
christians today that are like well i
want to have a testimony oh yeah so i
need to go out into the world and do
everything that the world has to offer
so that i get a testimony right and
that's the devil dangling the carrot you
know and he has no intention of you ever
coming back right once you get out of
the world he's like no i've got you i'm
not letting go so there's a lot of
people that deceive themselves or are
deceived by that that thought
and it's it's interesting you break down
the word testimony it just implies a
test
it doesn't mean that you failed
right right you do not have to fail it
just means that you are tested in fact
all of god's people
are tested
right and he wants them to come out like
gold tried in the fire it means come out
on the other side
brighter than before it doesn't imply
failure right it implies success if you
let christ lead you
and the other thing i've learned
recently too is um because i'm taking
greek
the
word for testimony in greek is related
to the word martyr
wow
yeah so it it it kind of changes the um
kind of changes the perspective when you
look at it that way what does a martyr
do you know it's like they give their
life
for the truth right he says you will be
persecuted hated by all men for my
namesake so
if you have a testimony you can just
expect that you're gonna be hated by
people and that was another thing i
wanted to say so
was that your first
christian song
no okay
so
and did it did it come out 11 years ago
or did was it already written and then
it took you a few years to get it online
it came out probably 11 years ago um
[Music]
plus one probably because the video took
longer to put together so the song was
out and then we gagged it and then we
made the video for it so because we're
like we need to have visuals with this
because i feel like a lot of it's just
going on
so
what was what was your first song about
your first christian song what were the
lyrics about because this is about the
enemies deceptions was what was your
first song about
my first christian song was a song
called wonderfully you
and that's
basically just me falling in love with
jesus
which is how it should be yeah um
it's
yeah that's the lyrics it's not because
of anything that i'll ever do
it's not because of any destiny you're
leading me through
it's not because any desires in my heart
you may come true it's only because
you're so wonderfully you
that's kind of how the chorus goes a
little bit wow yeah i wanted to um
go back to
where
you were talking about the ima like the
images took so long for the video in the
words of satan
and when i was watching it i did notice
that the you didn't hold back on any
images
and i was curious to know what made you
choose the images that you chose and did
you ever experience
any doubt in the process between writing
and uploading and putting it together
where it's like you felt like you were
going to get some negativity from it
honestly this was 11 years ago
things were different then that's very
true
you know
things weren't so um
smothered and kind of
um
trapped by the media and trapped and you
know truth it was different all i can
say is it was different then
um
i had no i mean i didn't feel any
problems to put the song out again it's
because it's my personal song i'm not
doing it to preach i'm doing it because
it's my life and i have a right to sing
about my life as an artist as a human
being i have a right to sing about my
life so i never had any kind of
like big question marks whether or not
are people gonna like this or think it's
acceptable or not i was like i don't
really care i'm an artist and this is
what it was for me
so
um if that answers the question nowadays
people don't actually have the luxury to
think like that that's kind of one of
the more sad things about where we are
right now is whether you're a christian
artist or a non-christian artist you
also kind of can't really think like
that
um
but i didn't really doubt no
um some of it was a little bit shock
factor but that's like i guess just my
nature
um
so maybe i could have eased up on some
of that if anything but
i i definitely identify with the shock
rocker thing i i used to be like uh
marilyn manson 2.0 or something so and
it's that's changed like when you said
that was 11 years ago i was thinking
about like when i first
kind of came to these truths and and my
style of presenting them to people was a
little more in your face and rough and
things like that um i was gonna ask do
you do you get pushback on that song do
you get people that
send you messages because we we get
messages all the time from people from
christians who say
you guys are the reason that people hate
christians and stuff like that and it's
like wow because we don't want to watch
things that blaspheme and mock my god
are you kidding me like it's weird how
people defend hollywood
and fight against their brothers and
sisters in christ who are trying to say
look this is garbage that is actually
making your god look bad
yeah we we eventually disabled the
comments i think the comments were up
for like two years
and then we disabled them because
it got out of hand and people were now i
regret that decision we should have just
left it we should have just let people
be people right
but we try to just maybe control that or
manipulate that a little bit because we
didn't like the way it made us look
but
in in retrospect i should have let
people be people um but we we did
eventually
disable the comments because
there was christians fighting christians
and it it just it got ugly and i didn't
i didn't like
how it was making a church look i didn't
like how it was representing my faith
like people putting words in my mouth
right i also i was called everything
under the sun bigoted nazi i mean like
everything you can think of like people
were just slamming us
and
eventually i thought you know what i
think this is losing the effect it's
losing the point people should have
their own conversations they don't need
to do those conversations online
and
i'm gonna take it down yeah there's over
700 000
views on there
i mean it's been up for 11 years but
that's working on a million views that's
pretty awesome honestly um
who what is your
main
band because i see like
when you perform there's a big audience
and stuff i'm just shocked that you
don't have more people following you and
maybe it's because
it's
people feel judged by it or whatever i
mean
is there another channel you have that
has like a million subscribers or
something because i'm just i'm shocked
um i have a band with my husband
currently it's our secular project
i don't believe in
christians only doing christian music
i feel like that is
grossly against the point
and i don't believe in christians only
doing worship music i also feel like
that is coarsely against the point
i believe that we are here to take over
we are not here to take sides
so i believe we should have more
christians infiltrating the boundaries
and the lines that have been dictated to
us by the media we should have more
christians on the front lines not less
running and hiding in the church
that doesn't mean that i'm swearing and
i'm singing bad lyrics i'm singing bad
songs
people are people they wanna they wanna
hear something that does something in
their hearts that lifts up their spirit
let them dig around and find out i'm a
christian let them look for that let
them find it i'm all about that but i'm
not gonna sing jesus in every lyric of
every song that i ever write because
that's gonna cut half the people that
it's actually made for it's gonna cut
them away from being able to ever hear
it right so
i i don't
and i know like there's not a lot of
people who might stand and agree with
what i'm saying but this is what i've
grown to believe which is why i put in
the words of satan part 2 out 11 years
after the fact which is also out now and
it's somewhere underneath in the words
of save in part one in the words of
satan part one was written about how the
devil
lies at you to keep you away from god
and to keep you out of the church in the
words of satan part two is the lies of
devil tells in the church
and that the lies that the devil used to
keep people away from each other and
away from god even within the confines
of church
and it took me that long to actually
live as a christian live in church
functioning
touring traveling playing all different
types of congregations all types of
denominations
and then kind of collecting this
information and going i'm actually
starting to recognize patterns that
satan is using to keep us divided
and
the whole thing at the end by this shall
all men know that you are my disciple
that you love one another the whole
point of the in the words of satan part
two is that the devil tries to keep us
separated so that we cannot actually
agree to disagree we cannot agree to
love each other
like despite the fact that we don't see
eye to eye on everything we can't take
the high road and just serve each other
in love and
i i wrote that part i wrote number two
or you know as i said in part two
because
that's something that i just i believe
that for the church like
prophetically for the church to move
into like this season and like
this time of the timeline of the world
we're gonna have to grow up and we're
gonna have to love each other and we're
gonna have to do it like and i wrote
that song that's my heart of in order to
say in part two that we're gonna have to
love each other
um
yeah as jesus loved us yeah because
jesus said you'll know them by their
fruits not because they're wearing a
christian t-shirt or holding the bible
or going to church every week
those are just these outward expressions
or whatever so
what i hear you saying is
you don't want to put up a wall where
people just shut you off and
we kind of talk about that as friendship
evangelism you know if your neighbor is
there and you go over and you bring them
some cookies or whatever and you just
start building this
friendship showing them that you are a
kind person because you have christ in
you
there might come a point where they just
say
you just always seem happy what why are
you so happy all the time or something
you can say because i'm a christian you
know i have christ in my life
and um so you're saying you want to make
music
that people are drawn to and then
they'll be like why is she always
writing you know
why am i drawn to this why am i drawn to
her and then when they search you out oh
it's christ in you i'm drawn to
yeah i'm huge on friendship evangelism i
don't know for sure if we're ever gonna
see
you know that if we're ever going to
live in the time of like you know the
revival tense with people you know
coming to jesus in the tent i'm like
they're not even going to come to the
tent
i'm i'm like i've got to be there i've
got to be present and i've got to love
the hell out of them literally
love the hell out of them like that's my
job now as as someone who loves god
just my belief with the fact that we
shouldn't
run away
um
we shouldn't run away and like you can
live with jesus and you can sing for
jesus and you can live for jesus and you
can be on the front line and you don't
have to
do it within the security of the church
and i i just feel like we've made we're
making that mistake artists are like
making that mistake instead of fighting
the good fight of faith being out there
yes you have to be smart with the way
you write your lyrics you have to be
smart you have to be adaptable you have
to be flexible but guess what i'm in a
room with people
who i can influence because i make that
music i'm not going to be in that room
if i just sing jesus all the time i'm
not going to be in that room i'm not
going to have that moment with that
person get their number and follow up
and be a friend i'm not gonna have that
moment if i'm not in that room
so
it's something that i decided to do
years ago
and
i'm holding on to it because even though
right now i'm not seeing as much fruit
as i'd love to see um i still believe
that it's a vision that god gave me and
i'm holding on to it i mean the amount
of people who send us messages on our
this is my the band lago
l-a-r-g-o
with my husband the people who send
messages and they're like i don't know
why the song just got me through the
pandemic like crazy crazy and i know
they're not they're not christians i
know this this song got me through the
pandemic thank you for writing it thank
you for releasing it there's hope
we are ambassadors of hope
why should we be ambassadors of hope to
the people who also have hope why it
makes no sense we have to be ambassadors
of hope to the ones who are hopeless
and
that's why um i'm gonna
stand my ground with this whole thing
and i'm just gonna i'm just gonna keep
trying to reach out i'm gonna keep
trying because i just believe that if i
die
and i stand before god i'm gonna see
god
you saw what i did i tried
i try to use my gift for your glory
because i try to use it to be a hope for
the hopeless i tried and
maybe the world will love me for it
maybe they'll hate me for it but i have
to stand before god
and i feel like
my conscience would be clear if i did
that i don't feel like i would have as
clear a conscience if i was like no i've
just got to make jesus worship music
because i've got to prove to everyone
that i live for god i don't need to
prove to everyone god knows my heart god
knows me and he knows that i'm only in
those environments not for myself i'm in
those environments because he needs to
put some little soldier there can i have
a little soldier there please because
i'd like to use somebody today but
everyone just wants to run to church
anyways i'm sorry i don't want to be did
you no see see what's great about that
is that you got in the room by being
yourself by being true to the truth that
you know right and um it just is
bringing me back to uh the lie that you
were talking about the first lie um how
is basically countering that because
you don't you didn't have to live the
same lifestyle lead the same lifestyle
as the people in the room yet you're
there in that room and going back to
keith's point i'd encourage people to
challenge themselves a little bit more
because think of jesus as christians we
are followers of jesus
jesus didn't drink he didn't do all
these different things yet he was always
around those people he was able to be
relatable to those people how and that's
something i think we should delve into
so yeah i was thinking the same thing
that candy just talked about you know
you're saying you've got to be on the
front lines like jesus was hanging out
with prostitutes and
drunks and all these things and he
wasn't doing it
but he knew that you can't stay in your
church bubble
and expand the kingdom of god i mean if
if all we do is hide in our homes
because the world is so bad and scary
and we go to church and hang out with
those people every week
we're not doing anything for the kingdom
i mean satan wants us in that position
he probably exactly wants to scare us to
the point where it's like oh if i just
keep them in their homes they're not
doing anything for the kingdom exactly
but the only way i believe that god has
given me a grace to do this is because
he set me completely free
i wouldn't do this if i was still
serving
the you can't drink from the cup of
demons and drink from the cup of the
lord right there's that whole scripture
i couldn't do this if i was still
drinking from the other cup
i can only do this because i know that
god has set me completely free
since the day that he delivered me i
never had a craving for any drug ever
i've never touched anything it was gone
and i cannot that's why
i think people run away from it because
they're afraid of their own intentions
maybe i don't know but i know my god and
i know the life i lived before and the
life that i live now and
i'm there's nothing in me that wants to
touch that stuff at all not just drugs
but the brokenness the broken
relationships like there is nothing in
me that desires that i desire to see the
kingdom of god advance
the
kingdom suffers violence and the
violence take hold of it by force that
is my flagship scripture if it feels
like violence it's because it is because
the kingdom of god is suffering violence
and we have to have a violent reaction
even within ourselves to be like no this
is wrong i'm not just gonna let this
like music be predominantly about
brokenness so that my child grows up
listening to music about brokenness and
that's cool i've got to give her an
alternative
i've got it
you know the same way you're talking
about all the the animated movies and
all of that and i was thinking about
that man we've been let down
by
i don't know sometimes i feel like we're
let down by the christians and the
christian companies who could have done
more about it why is there not the
equivalent to a disney animated story of
daniel in the lion's den
hi animation hi beautiful script high
energy music where's the equivalent
where don't tell me to put on veggie
tails
vegetables yeah actually as you say that
it's funny that you say where's daniel
in the lion's den
where's david and goliath high energy
cool songs that my child can learn
don't tell me to play salty for her look
i play salty for her i grew up on salty
it's the best best like i love it and
i'm gonna like sing that till i die
but
i feel like we've actually been sorely
let down because so many christians are
cool to just let their kids watch moana
hmm
you made it you made a really good point
about
your own struggles because
i've been set free from addiction and
that allows me
to be
you know sometimes i'll hang out with
somebody who
is doing those things because i know
that i'm not going to be tempted by
those things whereas if i was still
struggling i would never put myself in
that situation same with
any anything you know if you're if
you've got some kind of like
prostitution ministry or something but
you have struggled with lust you know
don't ever put yourself in there so
thank god he set us free because we're
in the same boat with hollywood we
expose hollywood movies all the time and
so
sometimes we got to watch the trailers
and kind of dig around and look at clips
like we made a three hour documentary on
anime and we had to kind of dig around
we're not sitting here watching the
whole movies for entertainment that's
not at all we're we're hearing from
other people oh i watched this episode
and if if you go to this scene i think
there's something in there so we'll
watch it and we're cringing like there's
there's i watch a trailer and i'm like
how do i even watch this stuff why is
everything so dark to me there's nothing
enticing about a movie trailer anymore
like when i watch it it turns me off
but
not ever that that mission field is not
for everybody some people are still
going to be enticed when they see that
trailer and
and we try to be careful with that as
well when we make our content because we
don't
want somebody to see a clip an example
we're showing and that just enticed them
to watch it
and like you said
where is the where's the funding for the
christians
the christian artists because
we
try to make christian t-shirts that
people can wear like this one i'm
wearing it says led by the spirit and it
looks like a led zeppelin shirt and when
we put it on our store so that somebody
has an opportunity to wear something
wear their witness and be a witness in
the world
they come at us with oh you're trying to
sell the gospel
well did you buy those nikes
did you buy that hat on your head you
know and it's like people will say i
can't believe you're trying to sell me a
bible and yet we'll spend 20 to go in to
see a hollywood movie so as they're
throwing their money at hollywood as
christians and then pointing their
finger at the christians saying you
shouldn't be asking for my money all you
guys care about is money it's like no it
takes money to make things happen
and so i've seen
cool christian projects but they're
really short-lived because there's no
funding veggie tales for example
he went bankrupt and now veggietales is
owned by some mega corporation
and the only and it's just like
it's like a show with a good moral
there's no scriptures it's just like be
good to your friends or whatever you
know and so what was
was what could have been
a really cool
outreach
is now owned by the enemy
so
i'm i'm curious
um are you familiar with the screw tape
letters c.s lewis
no
you know
okay
because everybody said oh you did the
screwtape battles i swear to you
i
wrote the song and i'd never read it no
that's that's that's that's that's great
i mean i was just curious if maybe you
found inspiration as a young person from
that but it also reminds me of something
else that was written
i don't know if it was written before
the screw tape letters or not c.s lewis
it was kind of old but there was a
gentleman called paul harvey in the
united states and he was a uh radio
broadcaster at his own show and he wrote
i need to send this to you he wrote a
monologue called
if i were the devil
wow and there's very similar type
ideas in his monologue
that's in your song so i want to send
that to you just so you can compare and
he wrote that in
so before any of us here at the table
were born are you sure i'm sure yeah
yeah
it's like
creepily prophetic because i know in
1964 the stuff he was saying seemed
far-fetched and now it's like he's
talking about our world today it's real
scary
yeah so we'll send that over to you but
i just i was
when i heard this song i was reminded of
those two things and i was like wow this
is this is
kind of
familiar in in one way and yet
so relevant to the times that we are
living in
that's crazy i i've never read that
before i'd love to read it thank you you
remember when you were talking about
your testimony earlier when you're
sharing it with us and you mentioned
that um you had
you this voice bossing you around
how did you learn to distinguish the
voice of god
your own voice
and the voice of a demon because that's
something that i feel like i struggle
with i'm like am i being too hard on
myself is a demon bullying me or is this
how god feels about me so how did you
how do you distinguish those three
voices good question
well first of all there's no way a demon
can bully you
because well not now
because you're a believer and
you are filled with the spirit of god so
there is no way that can happen for you
now
but i had given a lot of territory over
in my mind and it needed to come to this
head-on collision
and then it had to go
because it was it was being um
there was a lady praying for me
and she was just
commanding it to leave and so i fell to
the ground screaming fell to the ground
but then it was over none of this
exorcism
i'm dangling in the air like what the
heck not none of that
just i screamed and fell to the ground
and i knew it was gone
so first of all there's no way that
you're entertaining the voice of a demon
because he can't
it can't it can't speak to you now devil
can always lie
you know kind of around you but you just
always know it's a lie
he's come to kill steal and destroy so
if the fruit of what's being said to you
is breaking you down it's a lie
if it's making if it's making you feel
insecure about your life or insecure
about your decisions it's a lie that's
how you know it is there to kill and
destroy
but then as in terms of your own
internal voice and the voice of the holy
spirit
there's a difference because i feel like
sometimes the holy spirit is more than
you would probably do and it would be
more that you have to rise up to the
occasion
rather than
just do the normal for example the holy
spirit will be the one who says
or who makes me feel sometimes like
in when i'm leading praise and worship
you see
within all of this i am also a worship
leader that's the balance and that's
what i think is so important we can't
just do one and not the other sorry i
just i'm digressing but
when i'm at church on a sunday and i'm
leading people in the presence of god
the holy spirit is the one to to give me
insight and to sing things out that
there's no way that i can just be making
that up and singing that in the si in
the room looking around it's something
that has to have been in like
deposited to me from the holy spirit
because where would i get that from
that's what i'm saying it always it
calls you up for me the voice of the
holy spirit calls you up like um
it just
it's it's like you said jesus is a
gentleman god is a gentleman it's not
gonna push you up it's gonna call you up
it's gonna pull like
gently like this is a better way so when
i'm singing in the congregation and i'm
feeling like you need to sing out
against depression you need to sing out
against hopelessness you need you need
to declare
that we have victory over
you know financial frustration and
financial debt we need to declare that
i'm not singing it's not for myself i'm
not singing that for me
i'm seeing that because the voice of the
holy spirit is guiding me because
somebody out there needs to sing that
today somebody needs to come into
agreement with that
and
that's that's kind of how i can tell
the difference
right the the enemy is not going to be
like
speak against those things he's going to
say
you're you're stuck in this you're bound
to that um we had a we had a guy on
sharing his testimony and he was talking
about how he had
marijuana growing marijuana had just
become legal so he had a plant and he
had this mason jar just filled and he
was looking at it sparkling and he's
just thinking about you know he is
starting his journey with christ and he
was like
as soon as this jar is gone i'm gonna
stop smoking forever and he said he
heard a voice
and i doubt it was audible but he heard
a voice that said if you don't stop
smoking now you're never going to stop
smoking so that's what you're talking
about like that's not his own thought
his own thought was like look at this i
can't wait to smoke all this but there
was a thought that was saying no i'm
going to take you higher higher than
that marijuana can take you yep
i think to piggyback off of what she's
saying too
um if you've if you spend enough time
around a certain person
you ca their their thoughts their
mannerisms their words can rub off on
you
and i think it's the same with satan it
doesn't necessarily have to be his voice
it can be us
learning what his voice was like and
then our own emotions and our own mind
messing with us because we're
regurgitating the same lies that we
heard before so even though he's gone
and out of the picture
there's like a remnant of something that
can come back you know if we if we allow
it to so my wife and i we read this book
called
um
telling yourself the truth
because we lie to ourselves well we
learned that lie from somewhere right
but we can tell ourselves that lie
satan doesn't even have to be there
whispering it we can tell it to
ourselves
because we've heard it before
and so then you know our own mind has to
be that's where we have to be fully
surrendered to god and and realize no no
that's not the truth because god has
said this whether it's satan whispering
it or me entertaining the thought
either way
we still have to surrender our mind to
the truth like if you had some deadbeat
dad saying you're worthless and all that
and you grow up thinking no i'm
worthless well no god says you're worth
dying for you know yeah and so there are
people we see this all the time they
suffer 20 30 40 50 years later with the
thought of their deadbeat dad and what
they told them about themselves even
though the dad is gone just like satan
can be gone the lie lives on if you let
it
exactly
and i know you have to know i think your
own triggers i know my own triggers
like i know when i'm in a certain
emotional state that i am wide open
for the devil to just have a field trip
with me
because
i am maybe feeling like a little down or
i'm feeling this way or that way you i
have to know my own triggers there's
certain relationships that are triggers
there's just there's certain things that
i know are triggers for me and it's just
kind of guarding yourself like a bubble
i'll scarred your heart because out of
it is the wall spring of life a bubble
helps guide your heart and we got our
hearts and minds in christ jesus why
does he say god your heart and your mind
why and this you need to actually guard
your mind against these things that's
going to make you feel
insecure and
and yeah for me like i think rejection
is a big trigger like
musical rejection or you know like
people not understanding what i'm trying
to do with my life like that's a trigger
and yeah and just in security i just
think like all artists have an element
of insecurity about them and i'm not
going to say i'm above it because i'm
not so there's there's an insecurity
that i'll always have that i don't allow
it to be a trigger i don't allow it when
i can i
you know
pick up my cross daily but i don't allow
it to be a trigger in my life to stop me
from putting out what i believe is the
message that god has given me for the
season for the time that i'm in there's
a message there's a message on my life a
message of hope
and i just i have to guide my mind
against letting that message go
i like the fact that you brought out
your thoughts and your emotions and how
they play together because
you look at the bible and you look at
the garden of eden that's exactly what
was happening there you know there's a
mental ascent to the truth but then when
the serpent starts in
it starts to affect the emotions and
then the emotions again start to affect
the mind right so you have this
relationship between the two that's why
you have to guard them because one can
affect the other the mind can affect the
emotions and the motion can affect the
mind so you have to be
very careful you know that you guard
them that's why the you know the disney
motif even their ice capades is like the
follow your heart to her no no no no
you can't just follow your heart because
the bible says it's
wicked it's deceitful you know above all
else above everything else your heart
will lie to you
but that's why it's so powerful when
jesus said love the lord your god with
all your heart with all your soul and
with all your mind with all your heart
because we are we are mind we're a world
we're emotions all your heart with all
your soul which is like your emotions
and with all your mind and your heart is
like your will it's like there's the
three it's the trifecta of the things
that so if those things belong to god
and you want to love the lord your god
with all those three things then those
are the three things that are also going
to be attacked because they're the three
things that he said love me with these
three things your heart your soul your
mind
i i just wanted to say that um i really
appreciate just how you allowed the holy
spirit to work in your life
especially through the songs of in the
words of satan because i know that
right now in
just christianity in general what seems
like right now seems more like oh we
don't want to step on anybody's toes
you know we don't want to offend anybody
and it really robs the truth
and i know that people could listen to
that song and think like oh my gosh
she's judging me but
that compassion that you said that you
felt in that song i definitely felt that
when i listened to it literally over and
over and over again it's kind of like
waking up really
and you just want to run to jesus
because you're like oh my gosh like i
don't know how what i've been believing
this you know this whole time
and i just i just want to encourage you
to
continue letting the holy spirit fully
work in you
and to because i admire that you're just
not afraid and i know that's the spirit
of god because when jesus was here he
was not afraid
so yeah i hear that song as a warning
you know the bible talks about if
if you're the watchman on the wall and
you see the enemy coming it's your
responsibility to blow that trumpet
and we see a world out there who's just
been desensitized and
and raised in a culture that's so
consumed with
all these things that are not of god
but when our eyes are open because of
god's word and the holy spirit leading
we are to sound that trumpet or else
their blood is on our hands and so i
hear that song as a warning but it's
it's a perfect balance because when it
gets to the hook or whatever you want to
call it the chorus
it's just like you feel god's love he's
there and
i play that song for my wife and i'm i
didn't look at her but i'm pretty sure
she was tearing up every time you know
that that hook came because it's just so
moving
it lets you know that even though you've
been through all this stuff there's hope
and and god loves you and he wants to
free you from that he wants to give you
life more abundantly and pull you out of
that
out of that wretched lifestyle
yeah there was um
[Music]
i think
in a way too the song was kind of scary
because all i could imagine was satan
having like
everybody around watching him on stage
and he's just playing this really great
tune and it's i mean the song the way
you played it i mean like the the
strings and everything the piano sounded
really great
and it can just it's really when you
listen to the lyrics too and it's so
catchy and you're just like
the parts that are in the words of satan
it's like i can just imagine him just
tipping off his hat basically saying i
hate you all and we're just singing
along with it you know and that was the
terrifying part about it but yeah it was
it was really powerful
thank you
would you be willing to perform a song
oh yeah i do perform it
well
i mean on on here
cause i for one i heard your podcast
where you and your husband were talking
about the meaning of no robots and i
really like that because we talk about
that a lot how
the greatest gift anyone can give
especially god is the gift of free will
and you know because a lot of people
blame god why did he
make lucifer if he knew he was gonna
fall why'd he put a a tree of knowledge
of good and evil in the garden if he
knew they were gonna eat it
because without the option to rebel
you cannot experience love you cannot
give love you cannot receive love unless
that person has the ability to reject
that or rebel against that i can't
chain my wife in the basement and put a
gun to her head and say tell me you love
me she may say the words but i'm not
feeling it
when when she's allowed to go freely in
the world and she still comes home to me
every night that's experiencing true
love because she has the freedom to
leave if she wants
um so i like
i really enjoyed that and i want to
encourage people to watch that podcast i
noticed that there was a part one and a
part three i don't know what happened to
part two maybe it got
pulled down or something or maybe i just
didn't find it
but the song that i heard yesterday
was called shepherd and it was
i loved it and then i noticed at the end
you were tearing up and you were saying
how much you love that song too
i didn't know if you want to play that
song for some
hope and encouragement for people our
audience
sure i'll come and play whatever you
just don't mean today right
oh i mean right now
oh i can't do that right now okay
oh well maybe you can send us a clip and
we'll insert it in here
yeah we'll play the video i'm i'm not i
just i'm not really set up for that
uh
yeah that's gonna be rough
do you do you mind if we drop
your video in here
yeah that's cool okay cool yeah that's
fine
so this is the song i really like called
shepard we're gonna play that right now
for you guys
here's a song called ship it
[Music]
the shepherd claws and footsteps i'm so
closely behind
[Music]
in a unique way
they forced my eyes to follow in the
dawn in the dark
[Music]
laid down
like a dog who snuck his head out of his
leash
[Music]
and then you always
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
and all at once i understand
another chapter has begun that your eyes
have brought my feet some way
they never thought they'd come and just
like that i feel you and that my eyes
can see again and i feel certain
the impossible
will soon become afraid
[Music]
at times the weariness can make the
distance
[Music]
to make sure there are no bears or
wolves or thieves hiding at night
at times we feel abandoned but we know
that we are not
we
understand means that sometimes we feel
lost
but in your presence or your absence
there is this fragile truth
it costs my soul my everything
[Music]
[Applause]
behind
[Music]
and just
rising in my veins and i feel stronger
than the ocean when the waves are rough
and gray and in an instance i feel speed
begin to charge inside my legs like how
it felt when i was younger
all the blazing so unscathed
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
the cost of every journey has different
numbers on each heart
we carry each our own
the depths they cut to leave their mark
the cost in every heart cannot be wait
no be
till we get there
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
singing
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
behind
i love that song so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
it feels like a movie right
oh the baddies are coming you know
i love that song so much thank you
anything coming up for you any future
plans
in uh for your music and your band oh
yeah well we actually have a song coming
out on tuesday for lago
um
and
i have a pamela my book show on sunday
um
but what do you mean like long term
just if people are watching and they
want to connect with you or if they want
to follow your work what can they expect
and how can we we're on instagram where
we are logo on instagram and pamela
myberg on instagram we keep it separate
on purpose
um because
we want to see where that takes us
i've tried before doing it all together
under the same banner which was the
arrows
and it just got really confusing for
people who were listening and following
so when i want to be overtly christian i
do pamela marberg stuff and i say
whatever i want to say but when i want
to
use my gift for god to be able to put us
in a situation where i could make a
difference
without necessarily
just like by being a christian not by
doing christian things but just being
one
um
then i we use lago so we have a new
largo track coming out on tuesday and uh
pamela my book show um we have we've
been working on an ep that we're going
to put out for lago um
i don't have any new pamela marburg
material yet because i put out in the
words of satan part two
um that was a few weeks ago actually a
few months ago now yeah it's just
there's a lot of work
um
are you fully independent or i i heard
you you and your husband talking about
how
when you're with the arrows
um
your song before it was even finished
started getting played on the
radio oh yeah so do you get like i don't
know if you're fully independent do you
get radio play and
something britney said yeah something
britney said about
or maybe it was you i can't remember
talking about music today christian
music how it's just yeah you can't be
offensive with it you know with the
truth
and i didn't know if maybe that
if you have a
if people are
reluctant to pick you up as a
artist because maybe you're
too truthful yeah
too edgy with the truth yeah too
truthful too um we actually left that
label years ago the one that you watch
the um
the journey of largo i think or
something like that
yeah we left that label years ago and
we've stayed independent ever since
because um
as much as what it really it does help i
have no i know now what it is to have a
label and what it is to not
uh
there's parts about it that i miss but
what i don't miss is like
them just also taking a lot of money for
not really giving you that much in
return right
yeah
yeah all they do is they give you a
platform and and kind of give you some
fame but you have to make your own money
time's not even that sometimes they just
jump on a ship that's already sailing
and then yeah
yeah i don't know any labels who just go
here we go we think you should have this
no
no they need you to do everything
yourself
and then they jump on the ship and
that's why we were like nah we're going
to just stay independent and we're going
to see what god's going to do with it
amen
yeah what i've noticed with people who
get signed it's like
they're still struggling they have to
book their own shows they have to make
their own t-shirts to sell and that's
the only way they make money they're not
making money from the label or the
record sales or anything
it's just a very deceptive system
that we've just bought into since we're
little because they got a record deal
like on every kid's show ever made ever
in the world so we've all bought into
this like it's the only way that you can
become a musician
um
yeah it's like a big multi-level
marketing or something like oh that you
know those those systems they you get
kind of suckered into it and then a
couple months later you realize what it
is and you you bail out but then
somebody else is coming to fill your
spots so
there are there's already people filling
your spot when you're sitting there they
look at artists so like it's like the
stock market they look at who's doing
well and then they buy a little more of
that guy okay let's give them a bit more
money they're doing good and then not
that they've helped you do good they're
just like let's give them a little more
money they're doing good and then they
watch like a stock market and they'll
drop you
and then they'll pick you up again if
you're still around
and we just actually yeah
that's another story altogether but
we're gonna stay independent listen i'm
not close to
signing like a management deal with
somebody who's going to help manage us
and like move us forward and maybe be
more connected than we are i mean we're
south africans living in los angeles
what are the chances i mean zero besides
god
so i mean we're really open to having
somebody who's more connected who's a
manager to have somebody like that on
our team
but in terms of distributing your music
you really need a like
multi
multi-million corporation to help you do
that now even high school kids are like
just sending their music to spotify
right right you really
you need like a fortune 500 company to
do that for you i don't think so not
anymore you can totally be successful
independent now because thanks to
youtube and
itunes and all that i i follow one
artist and every every week he drops a
video and he gets over a million views
and he ends up topping cardi b on the um
itunes charts and it's like wow and he
has no he's totally independent him and
his girlfriend do it together yep
that's pretty cool i do have one more
question at least from me
um
so what is the meaning behind like we
are largo like the name okay that's a
little romantic
so you can't tell us then okay no of
course i can
i was like oh i asked the wrong question
um i always wanted to call
um our first child largo because it's
from an album
that we both really love and
kind of it shifted gears for me from
being like a jazz musician serious jazz
musician to being more of a
singer-songwriter and just being more
people-friendly i guess
so that was the album that kind of did
that for me
and so it was it was an album that meant
a lot to me just like an instrumental
album and i wanted to call our kid largo
and then
steph my husband said but you know what
we should actually call our
project largo because it is like our
first child
yeah
so then we were like yeah let's call our
first project lager because
yeah
well while we're on the romance thing uh
your husband was
in was the guitarist for your band
when you guys got together
you guys weren't together first
no
we weren't together
we were working together um
from
fully for a couple of years we were
working together but there was nothing
romantically going on
and then it was like
all of a sudden
like the lights went on in in my head
and in his head too i guess and all of a
sudden it was like
we were just clearly not really friends
anymore if you know like when there's
just that tension and there's just like
that
like that extra spark that wasn't there
before i don't know if anyone's ever
fallen in love with their friend they'll
understand what i mean which is
i i mean i i feel very i feel like a
privileged minority in the way that the
world is structured today i feel a
privilege i feel like i'm in a
privileged minority to have been able to
fall in love with my friend because
there's so much pressure around
relationships and who you can and can't
fall in love with and like this dream
and this like it's just built up into
the heavens it's just crazy
how people live up to the standard and
the expectation of what relationships
are supposed to look like anyway that's
a separate conversation so
when we fell in love it was obvious and
you know we had a conversation about it
like i was like i'm i'm clearly just not
really feeling like i'm your friend
anymore
and he was yeah
i catch myself every time my arm reaches
out to like
touch your arm i'm like why are you
touching his arm
that's awesome well
that's a really like you said a minority
thing you're you fell in love with your
friend you guys do music together i mean
i just i i always love that when i see
couples that come together and make
music i think it's probably
the best kind of music that can be made
i mean because there's such a connection
between the husband and the wife you
know
it's almost like you know you finish
each other's sentences so when you're
feeling the music it just goes together
perfect
yeah
he's my life partner in every way
awesome i'm just so happy that you came
on like
that song was such an inspiration i i
wanted other people to get to hear it
and
your lyrics are just so poetic i i can't
believe this second song was nine
minutes long i don't know how you came
up with nine minutes of
poetry but it's it's awesome so i want
to encourage everybody to check out your
stuff
if you guys were blessed by this
conversation and you want to check out
her music you can go to
pamela
myberg pamela myberg and largo and check
out her stuff
and we're just so glad you're with us
this week
if you were blessed leave us a comment
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we will see you guys next week
[Music]
you